hey what is up guys I'm Kim PhD here
with a quick word on tablets we got
tablets a couple years ago to fill the
void between the smartphone and the
laptop I don't know if we needed to fill
that void but what we got was something
that's a little more personal than a
laptop but also a little more spacious
than a smartphone and just a lot of fun
to use and it took off the iPad was
obviously huge and got a spike in
popularity pretty quickly a lot of
people could say it was just a bigger
iPhone and in a lot of ways it really
was but that was fine people love the
iPhone already and we did get way more
tablets that followed it in the next few
years now fast-forward to today and
we've seen an evolution in all three
categories and they kind of converged
our smart phones do more and more in
2010 the industry standard for your big
smartphone if you remember was the 4.3
inch display all the big smartphones
have the 4.3 inch display today
that's literally considered compact by a
lot of standards so the smartphones are
getting bigger as they're capable of
doing more laptops are also in a bit of
a transitional period too there are
still plenty of big laptops but now we
also are starting to see laptops that
are nearly as thin and as light as
tablets so that's again kind of blowing
a line and we even see some convertible
machines that kind of try to be both but
right in the middle tablets our tablets
dead well they've also evolved in the
past couple years have gotten better and
better and the best tablets ever have
come out the most recently so you might
not think so but on the other hand if
you look on paper tablets are a dying
breed by volume tablet purchases over
the last few years have actually started
declining they didn't level off they
started to go down 24 million tablets
shipped in quarter for 2014 16 million
tablets shipped in quarter for 2015
that's like a minus 20 percent
difference that's not a little bit off
that's a big drop-off and plenty of
research has gone into trying to figure
out why and it's sort of still new
category so there's no definitive answer
why people are buying less tablets but
you can see that the big smartphones
getting larger and larger and the small
laptops getting smaller and smaller has
sort of pushed tablets into this sort of
a specialty category they still do a ton
they have the best hardware they've ever
had they have way more optimized
apps they have better dedicated
accessories you can game on them you can
surf the web on them you can explore you
can take pictures with them and you can
do so much more on a tablet than you
could in the past performance is great
battery life is great tablets has never
been better but the total user base of
these tablets has hit its peak so
discovery was great that initial spike
with the iPad and all the huge
competition in the first year or two was
awesome and then it's just sort of
leveled off there are two main reasons I
think to explain why people are buying
less tablets now than that initial spike
number one is people upgrade their
tablets as often the smartphone industry
as much as we love it has people
upgrading every 12 to 18 months maybe
every two years your tablet you're not
upgrading every one or two years a lot
of people who are buying tablets for the
more casual stuff your light gaming your
web browsing your surfing that stuff
doesn't need a new model every two years
so you'll just buy one and kind of let
it sit around use it for a while number
two on top of all that convergence one
could argue that there's been a genuine
lack of any super exciting crazy new
features and tablets in the past couple
of years if you look at that tech of the
Year 2015 video and just look at what
tablets have been doing in the past year
- sure they've kind of pushed up against
what laptops are doing and tried to do
more but still try to stay as friendly
as a smartphone but in the end they
still find themselves somewhere in the
middle with sort of a niche and that's
exactly what it is at the end of the day
they're not dying they're just more
focused and that's exactly what they
need tablets turns out are not for
everyone they're a niche there was all
this awesome thews ii Azzam at the
beginning when tablets first came out
about all the possibilities of what they
could do but now we've realized it's
these pockets of users these dedicated
smaller groups tablets aren't for
everyone but they are for the parent who
wants to buy their kid not a smartphone
but still something to keep them
entertained or the casual gamer who
wants a bigger screen than his
smartphone but doesn't want to carry a
laptop around or the graphic designer
who wants a specifically a really good
stylus designing experience stuff like
that these pockets of users who are
dedicated and enthusiastic about tablets
are not dying they're just sort of
discovering themselves thanks for
watching talk to you guys the next one
peace